I'm going to take a moment here now
to talk about the problem we're going
to focus on for the rest of this class.
We're going to look at a certain period
of data, train our models over that
period, and then make forecasts and
trade over some other period.
So here's our historical data.
We're going to use the period of
2009 as our data to train our model.
You'll be implementing several
machine learning algorithms
to create different models and will be
comparing them one against another.
Then we'll test over the years 2010 and
2011.
So those testing values will become our
X which will push through the model
to create a Y or a forecast.
And using this forecast you'll
generate an orders.txt file
which you can push through
your market simulator.
We'll see how that strategy performs,
measure it's sharp ratio and
its total return and so on.
And that way we'll be able to compare
different machine learning algorithms
that generate these orders.
That's it for this lesson.
Our introduction to machine learning and
how it works at hedge funds and
other financial institutions.
I will see you online again soon.
Bye-bye.